from samba blockers in Brazil to masked
balls and Italy Carnival is a truly
global phenomenon celebrated in over 50
countries around the world Carnival
originated as a pagan festival in
ancient Egypt to usher out winter and
celebrate the beginning of spring when
Alexander the Great conquered Egypt
the ancient Greeks adopted the festival
the Romans assimilated the festival from
the Greeks
and it was later overlaid with Christian
meaning to become the festival of
carnevale the word carne means meat in
Latin and valet means farewell in the
Catholic calendar Karneval a farewell to
meat as he feast before the fast of Lent
in eighteenth-century Italy people
preparing for Lent would throw indulgent
fancy dress parties and gorge before the
fast as Christianity spread across
Europe so too did the celebration of
carnival colonization exported it across
the world Portuguese colonists took
lemons the shores of Brazil where they
had also taken an estimated four million
African slaves over time European
rituals fused with African ones to
create Brazil's world-famous carnival
the flamboyant street parties are a
celebration of Brazil mixed heritage and
it's big business
in 2016 the city of Rio alone welcomed
1.1 million tourists during Carnival
contributing around 900 million dollars
to the city's economy on the Caribbean
island of Trinidad the festival of lent
was introduced by French colonists slave
excluded from these celebrations created
their own parties to the soundtrack of
calypso music which mocked the french
this is now an integral part of Trinidad
Carnival in India Carnival is only
celebrated in the southern state of Goa
where Portuguese colonists ruled for
over four centuries parades occur
throughout the state the bands dances
and floats carnival is known as Mardi
Gras in the American city of New Orleans
and contributes over two percent to the
city's GDP Carnival is not just a party
in the Sun Quebec holds the third
biggest carnival celebration in the
world from humble beginnings Carnival
has become a truly global celebration
millions of revelers all over the world
contributing billions of dollars to the
party
you